she's the pride of Ontario and Oklahoma
and all points in between and also the
NFL Network my colleague from the NFL
Network stacy dales here in person good
to see you it's wonderful to be here
seeing you in this setting and gosh all
the years in the NFL together it's right
all the way back to ESPN that's right so
you're turning 20 115 yes Stacy you are
accurate actually that's the most
accurate you've ever been in any of your
reporting I thought 21 and 15 yeah all
right let's get to this real quick right
off the bat you brought me a birthday
gift which is in this red bag for the
radio on it so I'll describe it and I'll
I'll wait to take out the gift I already
know what's in there so does a
television audience so this was
Thanksgiving the HAR Bowl right it was
Jim versus John in Baltimore Maryland
and Steve bisciotti the owner of the
Ravens invited us all on his boat the
night before did right and we all hung
out some of us a little too late how
long did you hang out on the boat that
night were you were this the whole
entire time or did you or you I I could
forecast what was going on and I have a
way of doing that yes I sense danger
so I smartly avoided the situation yeah
I did not and I showed up for work the
next day and it was the football all
those years we did Thursday Night
Football no but I dunno what do you want
to point this out though it wasn't for
the night broadcast we were doing like a
game day morning yeah we did like a 9:00
a.m. Eastern kick yeah and so I for the
first time in my career showed up for
work at 7:00 in the morning thinking I
might not answer the bell for the first
time in my career like literally woke up
that day I got to work and you saw me
that day I had already been there
reporting yes like a good soldier yeah
and I watched you walk into the stadium
I have never
seen you like that in my lifetime and
we've known each other for what 15 yes
years were spent yes correct and I saw
rich who had just run a hundred 40s and
was probably putting backs and forties
and some cigars I never do like
literally never well I mean I do you
know an occasion take you know whatever
a liberty but not like that
you were unshaven gosh you just smell
the delicious scent of a really musty
cigar or show up to work that way
alright so then you came up with the
greatest concoction that I have actually
even brought up on occasion here on this
show what what is the what is the
lifesaver that you provided me that day
well why don't you open the bank okay
it helped she gave me a Gatorade a
banana okay
and then emergency that's right to
emergencies mhm
in a Gatorade hmm preferably a g2 okay
because that sugars just gonna crush you
okay you're gonna come down from that
huh and then the banana is like a chaser
you which like gets the palate better if
it makes the palate feel better
so you're you know you're your hangover
sorbet of sorts and and and and this is
for you I had an emergent have an
emergency on the way here but brought me
some of our I wanted to bring you
something unloved us that you would
remember did this bail you out back in
the day Stacy
well I was a professional athlete then
we went out on the road yes and when I
play basketball and no I just try to
stay healthy so you don't just be the
number three overall pick in the WNBA
Draft without having a trick of the
trade and any knowing any of that
service I'm Canadian
well the funny thing is is that we had a
Washington DC trip a couple of January's
ago and we hit it really hard then at
dinner and then the entire cruise showed
up hanging and I'm like I've got just
there oh yeah yes name them
view pretty much what you pretty much
met almost every human yeah we were all
there and guess what we did
we're like I'm like somebody's gotta go
get some emergency somebody's got to get
some Gatorade or and some bananas and
how did you guys feel showing off
without a hitch
[ __ ] went off with I imagine it was our
greatest show ever I think it was in
Washington DC so great to have you here
Stacey thank you for my birthday gift
you're welcome so you were in Packers
camp and were you there when the coach
blew is Achilles out were you there in
front I wasn't there I don't really know
if anybody captured that so he wasn't
playing pick-up with you is what you're
saying
pickup gal Bakula I would have won but
nice um
they were playing a game a knockout have
you ever played a game of knockout yeah
with my kid okay yeah it's it's
competitive I mean when we played
knockout in college or the pros or
whatever it was it's like blood sweat
and tears I mean cuz if you miss and
your ball goes to the half-court you got
to chase it down right over and then
you're you're checking it up there to
try to knock the next guy or gals ball
away right and I mean it's fierce and
we're talking about NFL coaches and
players I mean Matt Lafleur is a
competitor you've ever seen him so or
watched him coach and I just feel bad
for the guy what a way to start you know
with Aaron Rodgers who's older than you
as your quarterback and now you've got
to go through an Achilles surgery and
spend weeks in Abood and on a card and I
just feel bad for him it's a tough way
to really start what a serious note what
does that offense look like does anybody
is it because that's what we were
talking about Green Bay the last several
years was the McCarthy offense not
mysterious enough what's putting it in
the most I guess kind terms possible not
mysterious enough and not utilizing
Rodgers talents to the best of anybody's
ability that Rodgers wasn't believing in
it I mean
first blush results that you were either
eyeballing or hearing about would be
what it's it's it's odd to talk about
some of these offensive changes in the
off season because are they really gonna
happen so when I say the Packers want to
run the football more they do they do
they want to get the football out of
Erin's hands quicker so that he's not
getting beat up throughout the course of
a game and they're sustainable and then
you can take that long shot they do but
put Aaron Rodgers in the regular season
in a game and Aaron Rodgers is gonna you
know pull a Jim McMahon audible so you
know what I mean so it's they want to do
those kinds of things and you know it
with Aaron Jones and Jamal Williams in
the backfield and you know they got rid
of Randall Cobb but Geronimo Allison
it's gonna be healthy this year we
assume and Davante Adams is one of the
best receivers in the game and
equanimity Brown isn't a rookie anymore
so what is Jimmy Graham gonna get more
touches in the red zone right what is
for you know why they brought him in to
score so you you assumed Matt Lafleur is
extremely quarterback friendly and he's
gonna do these things but what will
Aaron Rodgers decide to do in the
regular season starting week one against
the Bears I know wait for it I know I'm
sure you'll be there that night and the
Bears of the team that uh you know
you've been closest in covering your to
of the naggy and true Biscay project if
you will your one was so phenomenal and
Jordan Howard being being sent packing
to Philadelphia which i think is a great
fit what what is the ad what what are
the expectation levels in Chicago here
for this team that was a double dink
away from being here in Los Angeles in
week two well see here the double doing
running our buddy Oh better be better
than twelve and four I mean that's what
they're saying
twelve wins isn't good enough in the NFL
and it's you think about all the teams
that go 500 right guys like it's so hard
to win rich in this league when I go in
locker rooms and
you know Negi is you know bu we not me
he's a master motivator I love being
around him sometimes write down things
he says because I am there a lot I live
in Chicago and you know there's so many
interesting coaches in this league that
brings something different to the table
and he he brings something different to
the table it's like when you think of
Shaun McVeigh we want to talk about the
offense right and how innovative it is
it's all the little things they do
before the season starts that you don't
see I remember Andrew Whitworth telling
me about McVeigh when he when he took
over he made a mission of learning every
name on the staff not just like you know
the football staff but all the
administration and he studied himself in
his meetings on tape you think about
that hold on a second wit told me that I
was like are you kidding me
because he wants to be a great leader
and really have an impression on his
players so you're saying that Stacy Dale
is here from the NFL Network here on the
Rich Eisen show so McVeigh would speak
to the team or do whatever he coaches do
with two players and it would be
captured on tape mm-hm and he would then
review that in his office hold this yes
when I was in London a couple years ago
you know Andrew Whitworth is one of my
favorite players in foul and just some
of the things that he told me as to how
one man can change a culture mm-hm
you think of Anthony Davis coming to the
Lakers and now their contender right
well when you get a contender for a
coach it's such an important job and or
quarterback the two you know faces of a
franchise and that's what naggy had oh
yeah the equation and he has this team
humbly in the palm of his hand
howdy what do you mean by that he's so
awesome rich he's such a great guy
mm-hmm
his teammates just love him he's humble
he's like one of the guys Tom Brady's
like one of the guys mm-hmm
you know
they want to play hard for him his
offensive line wants to block for block
for the runners and he wants to block
for true Biscay and and pass protect for
true Biscay and it's just a really neat
thing to watch when that culture thing
works you know so few teams have it so
you're that you're kind of a perfect
person to speak on all this being right
there front and center on the NFC North
and knowing the quarterbacks that they
are and you being Canadian what do we
what are we read into this whole
chugging of beers and the fact that true
Biscay nailed it
Stafford nailed it and Rogers again I I
might I make the excuse he's a sipper he
clearly sips his libations that's me I'm
up that I'm wondering how you handicap
this and in terms of the chug gait that
people are talking about right now well
if I recall it was the Washington
Redskins game last year I can't remember
that Rodgers played and he said he was
gonna go home and drink a glass of
scotch or something yes so he's a sipper
here's how I told Matthew Stafford when
I interviewed him a couple weeks ago ok
at Lions camp I have a problem with the
beer chugging the reason being is
because you have to qualify what kind of
beer you're chugging ok and I'm serious
on this this is really important I said
the Stafford what was in your drink I'm
what'd he say he's like well I was
having wine leading up to it so cool um
but I don't remember if he revealed
because I started it with mmm if it's a
Guinness or a Stella or like as I like
to call them Belgian waffles cuz they're
hard to take down that's one thing if
it's a Coors Light or a Michelob Ultra
we have a problem because it's so much
easier to chug water then the pride of
Canada yes ok so anyways I said the same
thing to Mitch and he kind of blushed
they were probably drinking bud Coors I
well yes he was in a ball game he was in
a White Sox game
you know you could get a premium the PR
staffs gone like hey dales it was really
a competition between david Bakhtiar and
kyle long
let's leave the QB a touch on here yeah
stacy tails here on the Rich Eisen show
what do you make of Toronto all lit up
for the Raptors what do you think about
this it's like what it means for the
country it's like the Caribana in
Toronto it's amazing it's huge it it's
electrifying listen I grew up in a small
town in Brockville Ontario in Canada
which is 40 minutes from Elmont Ontario
which is where dr. James Naismith
invented the game of basketball and I
fell in love with it when I was 8 years
old my first sport was soccer and so you
know when you're a kid learning history
in Canada you know who James Naismith is
it's important so it's really such a
proud moment for the country especially
when you know our national sport is
lacrosse but really it's hockey let's be
real mm-hmm you know there isn't a
household in Canada that doesn't have
the NHL hockey night in canada on and
with Don Cherry sure is mm-hmm he's the
best second year and you know it's
really cool just seeing this whole thing
will calm it up yeah and then the
representation Kawhi Leonard to be so
humble and you know I'll never forget
Doris the great Doris Burke interviewing
him and I don't want to be a hero
every kid if I'm a parent I haven't
blessed to be yet hopefully but every
kid every parent should like play that
back for their kids I don't want to be
the hero I want to be the best team in
it can be you know and for you know
superstar giant athlete like that to say
it it's kind of Canadian no there's a
sense of humility to that I loved it so
he fits up there in Toronto it's a good
fit for for him obviously nobody knows
what he thinks about what's a good fit
for him everyone thinks he's coming here
to yeah to Los Angeles and
the Talmud I mean he wouldn't have to
apparently he could live rent-free and
food free and drink free the rest of his
life based up there in Tehran but that's
not a joke like literally there's a
kowai NAND dine and that there is a
sticker in every window of every
restaurant and what was that the three
million dollar condo that somebody
offers really nice right so it's it
seems like a good fit up there obviously
they won the championship yeah but in
sports you know rich nothing nothing
ever can is a permanent fit so we'll see
what happens they love him there I think
it you know anytime you have a guy like
that a city embraces a guy like that and
will until he leaves or she leaves so
but it was really cool I have my mom and
my all my family still in Canada my
mom's texting me details like I just
wanted to let you know Kevin Durant's
out you know that he's the cutest it has
definitely been absorbed it's on the
game she's like did you know that Steph
Curry's wife is Canadian yeah that is
fantastic
and then what did you well I mean the
the u.s. women's national team won three
nil yesterday and I loved Carli Lloyd
when she of one of her two or two goals
she just absolutely missile doneand and
then gave the golf clap celebration I
mean what did you make of this whole
back right now right okay well done
barley from week one right I know we'll
call it week why that's a good call back
in clap back right there that is a clap
back after the emphatic 13 to nothing
win over Thailand yes she can you
believe she's 37 no it's it's amazing
what she's been doing last but how many
games in a row is that now SATs now six
World Cup games in row I believe to go
scored yeah
five or six and and can we can we pay
these women they're so good rich missus
the best four years
best of the best I mean substitute who
you want you know the coach made a
substitution yesterday and I watch the
game and I'm fixated on it because they
are like a scoring machine and it's
remarkable like you could you can take
one out and put another in and Rapinoe
didn't even play yesterday I think and
you know with Carli Lloyd like you're
talking about
there were liked a ten corner kicks in
the first I don't know it's eight
minutes of the game
if that's not forcing the issue a corner
kick is like golden soccer right it's so
important but you have obviously
competed at a very high level and a lot
of folks made it eight an issue with
that men wouldn't get the grief that the
women's soccer team got for all of their
celebrations and I know that this is
they've already played another match and
a lot of people think this is talked
about and over with but now that you're
here on the subject what did you make of
all the celebration conversation I'm
really cool with celebrating the first
six seven
eight goals maybe right um here's the
thing you're a powerhouse now I played
for Canada and we played in the 2000
Sydney Olympics humbly there were 12
teams we finished 11th okay we we got
there it was important to get there it's
hard to get to that stage you have to
qualify right so it's it's there the
u.s. is at a different level than
Thailand and what what you often see and
I don't know if people have talked about
this part of it what you often see in
games like that 13 to nothing which is
it's a record right doesn't happen I
think Canada beat Puerto Rico back in
the late 90s 21 to nothing the other
team the thailand's that they usually
get scrappy and they start injuring you
so clap
cheers to Thailand for not going there I
don't think that's in their DNA but a
lot of countries may have and taking
some low blows and cause some injury so
if if you're the u.s. you're fortunate
to leave in some of your superstar
players and leave without injury and you
know you have 23 players on your roster
I think so you know you could have made
a few more substitutions when somebody
scores five goals it's it's a big deal
for them but I mean it got a little
excessive it just did because the other
part of it rich is act appropriately to
where you're supposed to be the u.s. is
supposed to dominate that game right so
act as if so I love the celebrations I
also was always taught when I was a kid
play through the whistle and they sell
so kudos to them for that I will say so
it's kind of a you know you can go back
and forth with the conversation we did
in Berkeley said the same thing you said
which is you know kind of like act like
you've been there before and he told
stories about that you would take
somebody out if they did something like
that in the NBA they would literally you
would you'd be taken out well that's
what that's what I'm that's what you're
talking about exactly what I'm talking
about when I was in college my senior
year we we had an amazing team and
that bond that you create over the years
which is what you know the US soccer
team has and the US women's basketball
team and they're just dominant and their
system is so strong and the way they
develop players and Canada is getting
there with basketball which is awesome
but when you think about that and I
think about my senior year in college we
in the big 12 conference I went to
Oklahoma we beat everybody you know on
Wednesday Saturday by 20 to 30 points
and some teams started to get chippy I
mean I I was injured in a game because
of it
but you have to really be cognizant of
what the mission is and if you were
supposed to do it or not well Stacy
Jones you're the best you know how I
feel about you and I look forward to
with the rest of our colleagues gouging
the NFL for free food its impose night
tomorrow night do I say that into a
microphone I look forward to learning
with my colleagues about about
broadcasting over the next 48 hours good
to see you you bet at stacy Dale's on
Twitter and Instagram I follow her on
both you should as well for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 under red TV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app